well over the past few weeks we have
brought you stories of life-changing
event when it comes to heart disease and
heart failure so
we're going to wrap up our series with
eight simple things that you can do
today
to have a healthy heart and add years to
your life a few of those lifestyle
changes
start in your kitchen
everyone has individual needs dietitian
roxanna asani begins our heart-healthy
habits with number eight and seven
fruits vegetables and fiber we know that
most americans don't get enough fruits
and vegetables and they're really
highly nutritious for us right they're
loaded with vitamins
minerals and fiber and fiber is really
essential for heart health because it
can find the bad cholesterol in our body
and bring it out
number six ditch the butter and solid
fats
and choose liquid oils like avocado oil
and when you reach for seasoning
skip the salt instead use herbs and
spices and use a variety
all throughout the week to change it up
and then i would also say you could use
things like different vinegars or
different citrus
to flavor up your food as well and i
guarantee you won't miss the salt
number four reducing animal proteins
skip them
at least once a week you can definitely
use things like
beans or lentils which i have right here
that are also
really high in protein and fiber we
spoke to dr buddha dawn a professor at
unlv school of medicine
he rounds out the key habit changes at
number three
reducing stress by identifying your
triggers
some of those can be managed better than
others and some of those could be
work related some of those could be
finance related some of those could be
relationship related and each one of
those may have a unique strategy to
manage
number two start monitoring your blood
pressure
as young as 30 years old hypertension
adds to your
heart's workload and can damage your
arteries and the
number one lifestyle change smoking
would be a major one
research shows smoking increases heart
rate
tightens major arteries and also raises
blood pressure
which increases the risk of stroke
and by the way if maybe you quit smoking
to pick up vaping
it's not really doing much to help your
body commonly smoking was thought to be
more harmful
because the product is being burnt and
then smoke inhaled into the lungs
but experts are finding very similar
damage from heating up vaping solutions
and inhaling that vapor
and like the rest of the country heart
disease is the number one killer in
nevada